- Hockey Canada tente de
Après deux mois de scandale
pour avoir réglé à l'amiable
une poursuite pour un présumé
fédération sportive du pays
présente un plan d'action.
La fédération s'engage à adopter
du Code de conduite universel
pour contrer la maltraitance.
Hockey Canada veut aussi de de e
signalements et de suivi des
plaintes, et améliorer la
formation des joueurs et des
JOELLE CARPENTIER, professeure
à l'UQAM, psychologie du sport
- Ce qui est innovateur
c'est vraiment le fait
qu'on pense... qu'on annonce
qu'on va repenser la missiont ls
qui étaient traditionnellement
plus axées autour de la
compétition, de la passion.d'unn
fait partie des conditions du
gouvernement fédéral pour le
dégel de ses fonds.
14 millions $ d'Ottawa
en 2020
Me BENOIT GERARDIN, avocat
spécialisé en droit du sport
incontournable. Alors oui,
qu'ils devaient
le faire et je crois
qu'ils savaient que lacommissioe
arrivait à grands pas.
- La confiance de parents
Certains croient que
le plan crédible.
FRANCOIS LEMAY,
parent de joueurs
avec ce que les journalistes
ont trouvé. Auraient-ils déposé
un tel plan n'eut été des
enquêtes de "La Presse",
- Hockey Canada dévoile
de la reprise des audiences
au comité permanené permanené pu
Patrimoine canadien à Ottawa.ors
Pascale St-Onge et le directeura
sont parmi les personnes
le fonds de réserve de Hockey
our régler des cas
d'agressions sexuelles
Ici Charlotte Dumoulin, Radio-n